here we go here's the first team
steph curry and luka doncic the joker
who's the mvp kawhi leonard and giannis
so let me see if the second team flower
oh it'll be okay
all right yeah so that's your first team
second team all nba chris paul and
damian lillard
joelle embiid julius randle that's
julian lebron james
uh okay okay i don't know if i could i
don't know if i could argue with
anything i didn't
say i said okay third team i think i may
have a problem
third team kyrie bradley beal rudy
goldberg jimmy butler and paul george
so how how do we do chuck i have a
question for you
some other guys okay here's the only
things that i had on
my differences on from my ballot to
to what uh came out um
second team i had paul george um and i
had julius randle third team
all right and third team
i had to monitor bonus i didn't have
jimmy butler
and i had westbrook over beale is this
is this great
is this based off what you did this year
yeah yeah
so yeah so luca had a better year than
damon lillard
i don't think so okay i would switch
that
okay i'll put damon first and put luke a
second
my opinion sure no i mean that's and
that's what it is that's what it is
i don't think either one's wrong yeah no
i think damon had a
he he propelled his team further in the
regular season because it's a regular
season award yeah got a playoff award
right
in the regular season dame had a better
year in the regular season well luke had
a trick for you also yeah but his team
wasn't as good
portland was a better regular season
team than than mavs
miles are up and down but it's not
because of luca maps were a higher seed
yeah the maps had a better regular
season record
this is debatable yeah i mean that
really i think that was a good yeah and
i think the uh
they both won 42 games i like it i like
it as it was yeah but it's
it is like did anybody get uh have a
good argument though
what do you mean i'm trying to think
there's no one else well odie westbrook
wasn't on the list okay
but i'm thinking i'm too else and i'm
just i'm typing in the league well
jason tatum yeah that would be one yeah
he's got
he's got he couldn't be in the
conversation i'm just asking that yeah
jason tatum is definitely in the
conversation
uh ben simmons
in the in the conference the
conversation you know they on those
lists they have honorable mention
you go you good with lebron's second
team yeah because of the injury mm-hmm
um who was on the third team
put it back at all george
you want to see third team up here check
it out see 13.
kyrie brothers jimmy butler no the only
person
you know me no lebron's lebron but paul
george had a a good year
and he's really picked it up in the
playoffs but
uh but injuries man this injury thing is
a serious thing right now
the nba i said it a couple of weeks ago
the nba going to take a hard look
uh on two things i don't think we need
to send
our best players to the olympics nobody
gives a
crap if we win the olympic gold medal
everybody know where the best basketball
player and country in the world
to have the our best players really play
basketball year round as much as they
have
andrew olympic didn't start the season
again i think that would be just stupid
another couple of names donovan mitchell
oh donovan they're making
me make it here go back go back what
team did he make none no he made it oh
no that's not that's real
wrong the whole thing is wrong yeah go
back for bradley bill
the whole thing is wrong
the only thing he could have been
honking is 13. listen again you got to
take bradley
donovan mitchell is not one of the top
15 basketball players in the
in the nba then they're wrong about that
one that is not the right listen well
i'm not your question
no go to the third team please
but you could say the same thing about
kevin durant if he's not one of the top
50 he's not on there
yeah but this is there were so many
games missed by players
off the third team to put donald
mitchell on it i mean you only got two
guards
i i don't want to take anybody's shine
away today all i want
yeah i'm not gonna today is a great day
for those guys who make all the nba team
but donovan mitchell donovan mitchell is
a terrific
there's other guys who missed on those
lists hey bradley bill
and kyrie irving both had fantastic
years
that's no listen we love donovan but
listen you just
you have to make a number one seed why
why
are utah jazz the number one seed
donovan mitchell and he's
he's the best team right he's the best
player on the best team in
this record yeah with the best record
that's fair uh
that's impossible